l'extension du pass sanitaire est
approuvée jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022 après
plusieurs jours de débats houleux entre
députés et sénateurs le vote de
l'assemblée nationale de ce matin valide
la dernière mouture du texte au nom des
deux chambres après à l'opposition du
sénat le palais du luxembourg qui a
pourtant rejeté en bloc une nouvelle
fois le projet de loi la nuit dernière
pour ne pas donner de blanc c'est un
gouvernement les sénateurs appelés à une
clause de revoyure pour le 28 février
plus de précision avec estelle farges à
l'assemblée nationale
l'exécutif pourra désormais utiliser sa
boîte à outils contre locaux vides 19
jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022 c'est à dire
avoir recours à une batterie de mesures
de freinage de l'épidémie comme par
exemple le psl sanitaires ou encore
l'amendement controversé sur le statut
vaccinal des élèves sept semaines
députés et sénateurs n'ont pas réussi à
se mettre d'accord sur ce texte
principal point de discorde la date
jusqu'à laquelle l'exécutif va pouvoir
recourir aux mesures de freinage le
sénat avait opté pour le 28 février
mais l'assemblée nationale a retoqué à
cette date préférant se conformer aux
souhaits du gouvernement ce matin à
nouveau les députés de l'opposition
office ont fustigé le refus du débat de
la part du gouvernement ils ont pointé
du doigt et des mesures du texte qu'ils
estiment être incohérente je vous
propose de les écouter on se retrouve
finalement pour donner un blanc seing au
gouvernement sans encadrer les mesures
sans regarder ou peut-être à posteriori
avec un rapport que nous donnerait le
gouvernement où il mettra évidemment ce
qu'il veut de dents pourquoi vous arc
bouté sur une prolongation jusqu'au 31
juillet pour éviter peut-être tout débat
avant les élections présidentielles tant
il est vrai que pour vous la démocratie
ça prend un temps tout à fait inutile
vous installez le pays dans une séquence
sanitaire qui va coïncider avec une
séquence électorale dans lesquelles vous
impliquer un cadre d'exception un cadre
d'exception à votre main et tout cela
tout cela bien évidemment et bien
inquiète au plus haut point l'opinion
publique des arguments qui n'ont pas
suffi puisque avec 118 voix pour et 89
contre le projet de loi vigilance
sanitaire a donc été validé par
l'assemblée nationale ce matin être des
députés dans l'hémicycle ont d'ores et
déjà annoncé qu'il déposerait un recours
devant le conseil constitutionnel